didon et commence en beauté l'année
on n'est pas des humains on est des
oiseaux on doit partir dans la nature il
vit comme des oiseaux en blue il faut
que les enfants découvrent leurs racines
turques là tu vas voir on a quoi en
afrique
la nature reprend ses droits cette fête
olalala doucement sa fourchette
ok une rencontre on n'est pas les
derniers notre espèce c'est fantastique
qui va faire des étincelles et tout
vient doucement papa incroyable je suis
grand père chantait appelez-moi propice
au moins doucement avec papy toi tu
m'appelles monsieur par les créateurs de
l'âge de glace un jour va s'éclater
l'amazone ista va péter gras pop
papa tu sais ce que ça fait pas verlan
pas ses relais dans le monde
continuer à faire la fête je vais me
faire un plaisir de venir vous la gâcher
ça ne marche que quand c'est moi qui le
fais
rio le 9 avril au cinéma en 3d